and we are live welcome everybody to
another Google hangout super excited to
be here to talk to you about
entrepreneurship passion the
entrepreneur lifestyle I've got a
special guest his manga D me or PJ he's
he's an author he runs secret entourage
calm and we're here to answer your
questions and give you some guidance
motivation around entrepreneurship PJ
welcome aboard appreciate you having me
on Evan so you've got secret entourage
calm just so people have a little bit of
a context understanding of who you are
maybe it's like just a quick intro for
the audience absolutely surreal I'll
make I'll try to make it short cuz I've
done a lot of things but really my
background started in telemarketing when
I was 14
by 18 it was the director of the same
company as far as the telemarketer so
and I was able to be one of the youngest
bank managers in the United States
working for Fortune 500 bank at the age
of 18 and then my 23 I was a VP of that
same exact bank by 25 I got fired
founded two companies one really
well-known called the IP motoring that
can be found via team or net that
companies are huge concierge service
which was one of the first businesses
that actually anywhere in the world that
allows investments into exotic cars so
we did that since really I was 14 but it
emerged into what it has become today
since 2005 I also found this secret
consulting.com which was a training
agency that helped banks with service
and sales cultures that happened after
my long banking career and finally I
retired from a monetary standpoint at
the age of 27 where I kind of decided I
wanted to focus all of my life on
helping people uncover their potential
something that I've always had a talent
for while in my corporate career as well
as an entrepreneurship and so I founded
the idea of Secrets garage comm which
was a platform which originally started
with just telling people what the minds
of those that are that drive exotic cars
that are successful that are self-made
really do and it's evolved in out to
becoming a full online educational
platform focused on self-made
entrepreneurs who each have an expertise
in one industry all sharing their
our course and it's it's a
membership-based site that is a one-time
fee and allows people constant access to
new information being released daily and
weekly cool that's a lot I love it
there's a lot I have a lot of other
businesses but so so this section guys
is a Q&A you want to answer your
questions you can leave it in the chat
and we'll do our best to get through as
many as possible it's guided by you and
the direction you want to take it so
first question comes in from Sean who's
asking how can you change someone's view
on a subject how can you change
someone's view on a subject well you
know I think that the and I try to be
like I'll try not to be too long in my
answers but you know one of the things I
break down in my book their circle
theory is talking a lot about the way we
have our views to begin with right so
we're all byproducts of our environments
and so we form our views based on our
past observations and so if we have a
set amount of views it's typically
because someone has ingrained those
views in our heads or our way of
thinking the only way we can change the
way we see things is we change the way
we consume information we are given in
the idea of having an open mind but
there's always multiple perspectives on
the same exact topic and so the thing I
tell people is that if people are very I
guess one-sided in their view of things
and we want to change those type of
individuals to be open minded and allow
them to consume more information than in
get both sides of the equation we
typically need to come at them and talk
to them without actually telling them
what the answers are but rather showing
them what a little turn that it looks
like I use religion is a very very good
segue to kind of reverse violence which
if someone is one type of religion is
something very dear to them something
that's been braved with their whole life
it's hard for someone to come in and say
hey your religions terrible here's mine
you should take this one on and so I
typically think that the best way to get
someone to kind of see your point of
view is to kind of explain your end of
it and kind of let them come to this
place where you've evoked enough
curiosity for them to go search it on
their own and ultimately enable them to
consume the information with
sense of free will so so the whole idea
is to always keep both curiosity and not
imposed information and I think that's
the best way to change someone's Rihanna
ending I love it that the only thing I
would add is you could also influence
people through your action not just
through your words that they see you
doing something like if you're off going
to the gym and now you're looking good
it invokes curiosity people want to know
how you did absolutely and - I would
also question whether you need to change
that person's mind I think a lot of
people spend a lot of time fighting the
wrong battles convincing the wrong
people you know maybe you don't need to
try to convince that person maybe it's
not about a worth fighting sometimes it
is sometimes it isn't just I question it
sensation I writing in who feels like
has a lot of information about
entrepreneurship but doesn't know how to
apply it in real life so like you know
book smart on entrepreneurship but can't
apply it what advice would you give I
would start in some type of step right
like usually action creates momentum so
what I would do is if I had all this
information is the first thing is I
would make sure that I'm not
misunderstanding that having information
does not make you an expert on the topic
one of the biggest I guess problems Gen
Y faces and Millennials face is that
they consume a lot of information and
they automatically assume they're very
expert like in that field just because
of the huge amount of information that's
consumed I recommend that people realize
or align their views to the idea that
you know being an expert it involves the
idea of having mastered the skill by
practice and so we all going to start
somewhere with that practice and so I
typically tell people if you break down
any type of goal you have down to the
amount of activities you need for a week
a month a day and then you can actually
break it down even if needed down to the
hours what you're gonna do between 2:00
to 4:00 today and put on your tumbler
and actually get that done you don't
eventually see that these baby steps
will evolve and actually give you enough
backing to be able to say you're you
started on the path of doing something
and assuming like regardless that you
may have a lot of
that's with that pack for failure at the
very least that momentum has been
created and so the failure will lead to
learning the success will lead to
further action and it'll be kind of a
continuous model but it's just prepping
your minds to not look at the big goal
but rather focus on the small actions
that lead to the smaller results that
went put together lead to getting at
least 10% or 20% down to the bigger goal
or function of what you'd like to be
doing in ten years cool what I would add
is is to look at someone who's done what
you want to do and try to go work with
them go work for them apprentice like if
there's somebody you want to build a
marketing agency go find someone who's
built not a huge agency but like ten
employees 15 employees get as close to
that entrepreneur founder as possible so
you can learn how they're actually
applying it and building the business
that you want to venture go out and
build like go get some actual practical
experience beyond just reading because
entrepreneurship you can't just read
about in the book you got to actually go
and execute on the knowledge you have
and I'm glad you brought that up because
one thing that I think people confuse a
lot with this is they typically think
that you know every every person out
there that's doing it is doing it big
and I'm glad you said you don't have to
look at it someone who's you know build
a huge agency but sometimes taking basic
steps and is in the work because by
shadowing someone who's doing the work
you're even working there it doesn't
make you less of an entrepreneur if you
have a job so it's it's really important
to understand that sometimes you need to
bridge your way to the starting line and
to do so sometimes you have to maybe
work for someone you have to observe
someone else or you have to take these
steps which may not be immediately to
huge steps that lead to results but at
least getting you're on track to get
there cool pronounced right and in
evident PJ I failed badly in one
business I'm planning another one my
website isn't quite ready yet I don't
know if I should launch it or keep
working on it what do you guys think I
would personally say it all depends on
what the what the branding or concept of
the website is I mean if it's if the
website is the core of what you want
people to know and see then I would
certainly tread carefully making sure
you launch at least a product
that's somewhat representative of what
you're trying to do I do believe in the
idea that launching first and tweaking
later is important because it enables
you to create momentum it forces you to
work faster to fix things because you
realize that there's a loss component by
not fixing things
however if if your goal is to build a
web-based business and ultimately you're
talking about launching the website as a
result I would make sure that at the
very least the website is not turning
off customers even if it's not helping
you drive a man faster yeah as a concept
of the Minimum Viable Product like is it
is it just enough the people will find
me interesting and helpful I think a lot
of entrepreneur's and there's always up
is there's always something that will
need to be tweaked on your website okay
as soon as your website is done you're
gonna want to change it again and again
and again I'm sure like secret entourage
has been through a million different all
right
twenty twenty different events and
there's more you want to add to it every
right there's always something to add to
it and so yeah I mean I'm with PG on
that as soon as you can get it up where
customers are gonna get some value from
it put it up don't let the perfectionist
and you hold you back from doing
something because then you never get it
up
yeah and your customers will guide your
no guy kind of your future updates right
they'll tell you what your customers
want don't want and they'll help you
understand how to tweak things so don't
don't mistake that feedback you know
that you really need in order to keep
tweaking and thinking you're gonna have
the perfect website right at launch so
cool roshan asking what is your biggest
fear what's the biggest fear you faced
when you became an entrepreneur i became
an entrepreneur and actually not for
money a lot of people use ultimately the
idea of entrepreneurship first to kind
of go into small business ownership and
wanting to be independent from from a
monetary freedom stand-alone and for me
when i started becoming an entrepreneur
i was already a small business owner i
had done really well and so it was very
different my biggest fear for me was
always this idea of not having enough
time to actually do what i was trying to
do because i was trying to take on
something quite large my
long term idea with your entourage is
actually to change the way we see the
education system as a whole and enable
people a platform to really be the
beacon of what self education really is
and so you know with all of the new
platforms coming all the things
happening the lack of technology seven
years ago and all the things that we're
going on it was always this whole idea
that would I you know am i working fast
enough for gold at large before the
market gets saturated many things are
happening but that window of opportunity
ends and so it's almost like I've
leveraged my fear that helped me being
faster because that's always been kind
of the fire burning behind me is making
sure I don't run out of time
my biggest fear when I first started was
that I was too young that people
wouldn't take me seriously I was 19
years old I was selling to people three
times my age with degrees in science it
was scientific software I didn't have a
degree I didn't you know science was my
worst subject and I felt like they
wouldn't take me seriously and that
helped me back a lot at the start what I
ended up discovering was didn't care how
old I was
all they cared was it I could give value
like if I could help them then they
would listen to me and they would be
open to a meeting and and I was kind of
shocked at the start of the head but
once I discovered that and this still
allows me to go in and work with big
companies Microsoft and Dell another big
companies now because I know that I can
help them and so having confidence in
yourself and in your product was the
biggest thing for me when I was getting
sturdy enough and I'm glad you said that
I think a lot of people assume things
about themselves that's not really true
about what's going on in the marketplace
right like you know they assume someone
won't like that product or will consider
them stone so and yet like you know
what's actually going do it they realize
how little of a concern that really is
in the marketplace but rather it's just
all in their heads yeah so my fault
question has that changed has your your
fear like what are you more afraid of
now compared to when you were starting
this house your fears changed no I think
I mean when I was starting in business
obviously that was very different than
when we're starting in entrepreneurship
I think most people jump into
entrepreneurship and for me after
very gradual road like I went really off
in corporate America have two businesses
that successfully like didn't really
well monetarily in the business world
before jumping on in this idea of
entrepreneurship and so I think my mind
was very much trade for most of the
fears people face from there trying to
start a business while being an
entrepreneur which is you know something
that you have to go to that roller
coaster I had already gone to it so many
times for these other variables that for
me it was a very systematic process
where I was almost able to bring the
idea of entrepreneurship down to this
process driven model that was almost
like building a business so it was very
very easy in that aspect of it you know
and it was more of an internal sphere
that it still plagued me today like I
meaning it in a different way it's that
it's the same fear just in a new form
it's just this idea of running out of
time especially because I don't know if
you know but if you'd like months ago
diagnosed with cancer would actually you
know survive now but not gonna like you
know I'm okay for now but you know when
that hits you and you're like wow like
that was only one small but imagine what
a big bump could you know could really
derail that half you know am I really
prepared to allow my legacy to carry on
past myself so I love it LP 91 I'm about
to apply for a master's in architecture
but it doesn't fulfill me yet it leads
to a job which I can use to fund me the
to branch out later on what's your
opinion
I'm all for breaking your I mean we
talked about this routine you're like
bridging your success or bridging your
way entrepreneurship sometimes I didn't
love my whole corporate America career
but I found something within it that I
really loved then it became really good
at it I think sometimes you know if you
don't have something better
specifically right this moment if your
ideas like do I get a masters and become
an architect and you know maybe at some
point I'll find something or what do I
do now if that alternative doesn't look
better right now I would just find
purpose in what you're doing and really
do it in the best shape or form I think
one of the biggest habits I can advise
anybody to go over gotta see you've got
a formal education or Southend addition
is whatever you doing like always know
why you're doing it and and outside of
why
doing it make sure you're ready to put
your effort in it because there's no
point in doing it if you're not gonna do
it well yeah I think the point of a job
is to learn if I was going to take a job
somewhere it wouldn't be just to make
money it'd be to learn how to do
something because that's gonna be way
more valuable to you longer-term then
then the money you're gonna make so you
know is this job that you're gonna get
gonna teach you the skills to then
branch out and be an entrepreneur or if
not then how could I get a job where I
could learn those skills and maybe the
BRIT like I agree with PJ I think the
bridge is great I I'm not the guy says
burn all your boats and go all-in and
then you run out of money in three
months and you're you know back trying
to find your old job but could you go
work for a smaller architecture firm
right and get close to the entrepreneur
and learn from them and take on more
projects you know no entrepreneur owner
is gonna say no I don't want you to take
on more work right like be the
hardest-working guy there learn about
the business so you're not just doing
the stuff that you went to school for
but you're actually you know being
mentored by this architect where you
gonna learn the skills that's why you
want to take the job
so wouldn't you see it as hey I can make
you know ATK and then I'm gonna save up
that money to start my business no like
you're losing a lot of opportunity costs
to be just point about wasting time like
you're wasting time here you should be
learning from the next job opportunity
that you get absolutely buh buh buh buh
buh what's next young more I love his
hat what's the story yeah he was just
driving I was just driving my white
Lamborghini in I have a matching hat for
every one of my cars
I'm a big exotic car collector so I have
a matching hat to all of my cars and I
ran upstairs real quick to make sure I'm
not late for this cuckoo and yeah I
forgot to put my hats yeah hey yes the
question you get an answer the next shot
Robocop or terminator uh that's a tough
one it is which terminator but I'm gonna
probably go with the idea of Robocop I
don't know that I watched all the
Robocop so I just go candy but I like
the idea of being a good guy more than
the bad guy although
terminator was a good guy
as this one right yeah it's true there
you go we're both hedging a little bit
but I'll go Terminator just for the
controversy Jay passed thank you for
this guy's how do you find the right
support how do you approach those that
have been successful the finest employee
that's a really good question and
something that comes up a lot even in my
own Academy it's you from sparks where
people are like how do you approach a
mentor how do you first someone who's
been really successful and talk to them
I think you know most people think about
mentorship or approaching people in a
very formalized way they feel that they
have to kind of introduce themselves
create kind of this environment where
they're like we're gonna you're gonna
now teach me something I'm gonna sit
down and listen and that's what I'm
trying to get a lot of times if we pay
attention we can meet people who are
very successful or people we want to
meet in places that are a common ground
meaning that let's say you like cars
right and you're a guy that knows that
half of the people that show up at these
big car meets with Ferraris Lamborghinis
are people that you want to spire to be
like or you want to learn from well
nothing prevents you from showing up at
these car meets and engaging in car
conversation and slowly getting to know
people when you get to know people
obviously those who have the type of
personalities that are willing to share
that wanna share I think they'll just
start opening up and talking to you
about cars business and everything in
general and so that allows you an
opportunity to first listen and create a
friendship and create some type of
opportunity to open further conversation
and regardless that it's you meet those
people once a week at the same car place
until eventually becomes a real
friendship and they invite you over to
lunch or dinner or whatever it is or
that it's just the kind of informal talk
from time to time the idea is that if
you receive advice if you ask a question
and this isn't a debate I think the
biggest mistake people make is that they
feel that they need to express their
views on the situation if you really
want information from someone or
mentorships pay attention to what you're
being told because every word everything
they brings up is based upon experience
itself and so I typically tell people
you know if you want to meet people find
where those people may hang out go
engage in basic real honest
conversations or
they're about business graph and you'll
notice those that are willing to share
nearly volume into a better relationship
yeah I love PJs start small approach I
think too many people will email off and
say hey will you be my mentor and that
applies that implies like a that's a
relationship right nowyou I'm not going
to be your mentor right we're the
biggest thing for a mentor understand
that there's value both ways like a
mentor wants to give back people have
had success they do want to get back to
do want to hear do you do want to see
other people learn from them there's a
feeling of contribution that really
helps them but they want to see that
you're actually hustling and you're
applying that knowledge there's nothing
worse for a mentor than having giving
great advice and then seeing zero action
follow up as a result and so I would I
love Paige's approach startup start
connecting with people whether it's
offline online but with something small
and show your hustle and if they give
you a little bit of knowledge apply it
and then come back and say I apply what
you said here's what happened and then
you can go for a little bit more and
that that shows the value that you're
like you appreciate their time and their
wisdom and you're hustling hard they're
gonna give you more much better than
just going up and saying hey be my
mentor yeah always keep it genuine I
think that's the key thing be yourself
be authentic and find people who are
authentic to their own rights and find
that connection in between so that real
relationships will lead to mentorship so
dr. Yasin is asking may I know what you
think that you feel is totally different
than the way others think what do I
think that I think is totally different
in the way other extent ah I I mean I
think one of the things that I do that
makes me super gay maker in the way I
see or think is that I never make
excuses to why things don't happen I I
think that's one of my greatest
strengths is that if something can
happen it I find a way to make it happen
I never find a reit like the first thing
that comes to my mind isn't why
something wouldn't work or rather how to
make it work and I think that regardless
that is a problem within the company the
idea to start a new company yet you just
start a new venture
writing the book it's always looking at
it from from the process aspect quickly
rather than allowing it to have an
emotional reaction before the process
you know like if you look at a lot of
work you might get scared and like oh my
god it's a lot of work or you know I'm
not even having that the reaction and
immediately process eyes and get to a
point where how can we take action on
this like in an hour not in six months
or in a week and I think my training
mentally with myself having done so many
times has become just the easier way for
me to look at every problem and quickly
solve them and it's actually almost made
me happy to have problems because I
think like most entrepreneurs we strive
in chaos like you know when there's a
chaotic environment we feel useful and
so when we've kind of leverage that
skill enough over time I think it makes
it very easy for us to even find more
purpose within problems and find a way
to make problems into great
opportunities and move forward and I
think once you learn to do that fast
enough the more successfully become I
love it for me
it's written on the wall blue I believe
in people more than they believe in
themselves I see potential in people and
the thing that bothers me the most is
untapped potential we see someone who's
got insane amount of skills and and
they're holding themselves back with
limiting personal beliefs and so he's
kind of taking the onus and
responsibility myself to help them push
through and realize a better vision for
themselves
I think people limit themselves too much
in their mindset so I really get a
mentor Sean is asking how can you break
out of old habits that are deeply
ingrained in your system the I think the
only way you can break old habits is
simply to realize that you're the only
one that's constantly doing them over
and over and over so you know I think
everything comes on itself
accountability more than anything else
you know there's a quote that I just
love it's like delays the greatest form
of denial you know everybody's always
like oh my glitter gym starting January
I'm I stopped smoking
next month you know I'm gonna set these
like time tables that are like away from
you know something in it all of this is
just a delay form of not wanting to stop
doing something that you know is bad for
you and I think the day you start
realizing that it's in your control if
you gender you want to stop smoking you
put it down that moment not a day later
an hour later you do it right then and
there if the habit is destructive you're
going the wrong places at the wrong time
stop going you know like make that
choice and realize it's in your hands I
think that the earlier you take self
accountability into action the earlier
you start forming new habits and I think
sometimes to transition an old habit
into a better one you have to take a
medium habit like something in between
the two that allows you to stay occupied
soar your mind doesn't want to do what's
easy right you know it's the same as
saying you have a relationship with
someone and then you typically have a
person in between that relationship in
the next meaningful one is typically
because the habits that take place in
that relationship it's hard for you to
just let them go at once so you replace
that person that's toxic in your
environment with a new person before you
find that other meaningful person you're
like now that's what people typically do
that's not what I recommend people do
but if you're strong enough then you
realize what's good for you and what's
not and you just make a choice and I
think that the key is to realize that
every choice you make has no good or bad
associated to do but it's rather a
choice and the actions you take out the
better choice are gonna lead to the
consequences you think I love it
I think the first step is understanding
that most of your habits are
subconscious and in the first I'm just
awareness like awareness that you're
doing something wrong awareness and
understanding so like to pjs point about
relationships you know if you've had
relationship problems in the past you've
gone through you know three four five
six seven relationships probably same
things keep coming up over and over and
over again and it's not them it's you
like there's something that you're doing
to the the consistent thing here is you
in the relationship and so it's you're
not even aware of the things and so a
lot of the limiting beliefs and mindsets
and habits that you have you're not even
aware of it you just do it naturally
it's so subconscious and so the first
step is just that awareness the second
step for
would be doing like Monday night
quarterback like realizing afterwards
that you made the mistake like I should
have said that like I did it again you
know you catch yourself later and then
the third step is actually catching
yourself in the moment like I'm doing it
again I'm doing again right now I need
to stop and having the courage to stop
because you've been doing it for you
know years decades maybe having a
courage to not do it and take a
different route the speeches point about
just making a decision like I'm gonna be
this new person now I think you're so
many of those habits I think something
like smoking might be a little easier
because you see it visually all the time
but I think so many of the habits are
just like you know locked in your head
things that you do how you react to
situations like you might just naturally
run away from a problem you know
peih-gee and i might thrive in a in the
chaotic environment others would be
scared and like that's just their
default is to run away and hide and
until you catch yourself doing that and
realize that that's actually a problem
then you're never gonna change it Raquel
how can you start a business with
without a lot of money that's a very
subjective question I think it's a very
common question but I typically I've
come across in the past seven years
we've had C Brown Suarez and we've been
asked this question probably like almost
over a thousand times I typically tell
people there's there's two things you
need to consider when you ask that
question the first one is that most
businesses don't require a lot of money
typically there's this this idea you
need a lot of money but every time you
don't have money you have to substitute
that with sweat equity right so any
amount of money you don't have any need
upfront you need to figure out a way you
can either do the actual skill required
yourself or persuade someone to do it
and work alongside them learn from them
whatever it is you're gonna end up
losing the time for the money you don't
have a friend that's something you just
need to keep in mind the second piece is
if you haven't been able to save enough
capital to even have enough leverage to
maybe do some of the basic things you
need such as you know getting your
web-hosting maybe what
or whatever it is you need to get
started you need to consider the idea
that perhaps you're not in a position to
be the one starting a business right
that alone you need to first work on
your personal ability to save money
manage finances and do the things you're
going to be doing for a business anyways
because you haven't been able to be
doing that successfully for yourself so
it's almost like saying why would you
want to put all that burden on yourself
to not jump into another business and
handle that as its own entity while we
manage your money and the money of the
business right so these I mean this is
our reality people face is everybody
wants to get in business to make a lot
of money well if you as a human being
hasn't have not been able to find the
way to save money and make money you
have to consider that why we could be
the person eating a business that is
going to make a lot of money so perhaps
before you jump into it I tell people
grow some skills and throw out to learn
better ways to manage make or understand
how money is made to begin with so that
you can translate that into the business
but to answer that in a generic format
business in most cases does not require
a lot of money or any money per se you
know and we started started how many
businesses with fewer dollars and in
businesses that people would either look
for an investor or would typically tell
you hey you need a lot of money to get
in that line of work and the reality was
no you don't like it took me longer it
took me three years of bridging that gap
having to be enough capital to do
exactly the business the way I wanted it
but it still started in a still took
place but again that took a lot of
self-discipline and a huge background
and in corporate America especially in
finance understanding money store was
never the question of did I have enough
money for myself and it was always the
idea that did I understand money itself
yeah I would echo PJ's points there I
think any business almost can be started
smaller with nothing just invest your
hustle your heart your energy I have a
personal rule if I don't like spending
money till I'm making money
so like find a way to make money put
your and it look even now like when I
started my youtube channel I had money
from my business but I didn't go and buy
the gear and hire the team and get the
lights and all that stuff I started with
with
my camera myself I'm just started
filming and yeah I took longer but it
wanted to make sure that I was actually
interested in it
20 people go and they buy all the gear
and they buy the supplies in inventory
and then they stop
you know like I'm gonna get into the
statute business and I'm gonna buy ten
thousand statues I'm gonna fill up my
garage and then you know I've taken out
a loan on my house right now I'm gonna
be in debt for the rest of my life
because I've only sold three of them and
they're just sitting there and that's a
big mistake that people make like you
when you're taking money into your
business you want to make sure that you
have something that you know works like
expansion my name is final okay we made
it here now we're gonna grow national
great you have a model that works at the
start you don't know what you're doing
so prove to yourself that it's worth
doing before you potentially get in debt
for the rest of your life y'all excited
they're such a distraction you know like
if you have all the lights and
everything for your YouTube channel
right after that I mean it's so much
work by itself to manage that it
actually keeps you from doing the work
itself that's a good point - good point
Bolinas writing do you meditate what do
you do to relax actually this is your
really weird one I have a weird ritual
for relaxation so I clean cars so my
only time of peace mentally meaning
Graham completely away from work away
from anything is I have a really nice
car collection and I love cleaning cars
and what I mean by that is I mean
detailing them I find a lot of beauty in
design of exotic automobiles and I
actually enjoy waxing them like The
Karate Kid on and off all by hand and
really getting into it and it's really
it's really weird because it's like even
my whole family my wife everybody knows
if I'm in the garage it's like do not
disturb know it like don't come in the
garage don't like leave me alone with my
cars it's the only time where I sell
fruits like either that or I go running
every night for about two miles and I
don't do a single like anything more
than two miles and during those two
miles
it's my most creative time where I'm
like almost like in meditation life so
really weird but it is what's worked for
me since I was very little so I like it
the cleaning car meditation I liked it
I've tried a lot of different for
meditation I've never stuck with
anything I haven't felt it enough and
maybe I haven't talked to the right
person or what but I don't have a
regular practice of meditation to relax
my to go to sr1 salsa dancing but I also
own a salsa dancing business so it's
kind of working relaxed at the same time
but I got into it out of like passion
for dancing or to like if I'm up late at
night I just can't sleep and I got just
a ton of stuff on my mind I'll actually
get up and play a game of League of
Legends and then that's just like quiets
my business brain down and I can go to
sleep afterwards so those two things
helped me dancing and League of Legends
next question I know we're running a
little short on time I want to know what
your biggest secret is behind your
business secret I think I think my
biggest secret in terms of like the
secret to our success so far in any of
my businesses has always been not being
lazy and what I mean by that is we all
have a different view of what lazy is
you know some people consider it to be
like I work the eight-hour day I'm not
considered lazy you know a 12-hour day
or they keep stacking up the hours I
think that you know for me it's always
been this this lack of fear towards the
work that's what I consider not being
lazy you know like when I see the word I
don't have this reaction to it like oh
my god it's a lot of work but literally
the second after I'm already starting to
work on the solution because there's
only so much time and I figure why to
worry about something that's gonna need
to happen anyway and I think the secret
is that I've never lost momentum in my
businesses because I've never been
afraid of what's ahead even what we
don't know that's ahead that may happen
and I've always understood that with the
right process the right amount of work
and more importantly the right amount of
people but the right people behind you
working with you and that you thought
that you're bringing up and I'm dying
right leading along the way I think that
no business can feel you know unless you
choose to give up on it and move away it
changes from what you originally thought
it may look like the cross
maybe different the challenges may be
different than ones he originally
thought he faced but I think the real
secret to the success of all of my
business personally has always been that
always consider myself to be someone who
does the work or find someone to do the
work without that gap of time trying to
worry about what to do of the work and
we kind of talked about that earlier too
but funny or not that's also the license
plate on one of my exotics is not lazy
so I liked it I liked one of the words
PJ user momentum and the way I channel
that is I always follow my curiosity
things that I'm interested in I'm
excited by even if it doesn't
necessarily make sense in the context of
my current business I'll just start
doing I'll just even in a small way
again not investing time and since are
not investing my money into it just just
my time I hustle because I think too
many entrepreneurs box themselves in to
doing what they were doing and often
that becomes an anchor like your past
success can be an anchor towards your
future growth and so whenever I get
excited or interested in something I
just start trying it and maybe it
explodes and doesn't do anything and
maybe it takes off but not being afraid
to follow your curiosity one last
question
YAG more writing in how did you find
this business because I can't decide
what business I should do so how do you
how do you find the business that you're
meant for so it always comes down to the
idea of where does your passion come
from because you know a business is just
finding a need and fulfilling that right
like there's a need out there or you're
creating a want for a product and then
fulfilling that by being the solution I
think for me I mean from an
entrepreneurial side the way passion is
born is when we understand we understand
what our skills are we elevate one of
our skills to become a talent what we're
naturally better at and then we link our
talent to something we love so if we're
talented writers can we love cars
maybe our destinations are keep going
right cars all day or maybe you write
about right like in a blog and a column
as a journalist like so in other words
we take what we're very telling to that
like that we figured out what our time
we've grown our skills enough we match
it to something we love and then we
allow that magic to happen where the
passion fuels this idea that eventually
uncover your purpose yeah and to echo
PJ's point there I was here you need to
explore you got to try some people know
what they want to do like they get
absolute certainty and then this is go
do it and sometimes they don't and in
the same person can have those periods
in their life where sometimes you have
clarity and sometimes you don't and when
you don't you have to explore the worst
thing you can do is pick up you know ink
magazine of the hottest hundred
companies to start and just go do pick
one of those so you have no idea what
it's all about just because the industry
is blowing up and it's hot you have to
bring some of yourself your passion you
love your energy to the business and if
you don't know what that is yet then go
out and explore you're not gonna be able
to find it just by thinking about it you
have to actually try and get in it in a
small way to see does this thing make
you come alive or not and if not then
have the courage to keep going to try to
find the thing that you're excited about
even though you don't know what that
path is gonna be it's a scary path it's
an unknown path so people settle and
that's not the way to build a great
business everybody cool pj man thanks
for all the times that amazing still
tons of questions for people to want to
learn about you figure what all the
stuff you're up to what's the best way
to get in touch on two easy ways the
best one is to go to my personal site
WWF on udemy calm and the other one is
to visit super entourage academy and
communicate with me Derek's WWE secret
academics calm and that's the same place
you can pick up my book their circle
theory as well I'll ever thank you man
for the time thank you guys for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon
always thanks again for having me on
happen okay